Je suis vraiment désolé,
je pensais que votre vide euh je viens d'emménager dans
lequel pour vous comment 35 nous sommes en
bas plus de sortes de bâtiments d'ombres
loin d'être aussi homogènes que le système
aimerait penser quand vous regardez ce qui se
passe dans la rue  bruits les bons
les enfants sont rentrés loin de la
piscine ce matin venant trop
bruyant sous l'autorité de qui m.  royal
veut te voir pour le thé
Oh doc : tu as construit tout
ça comme un [ __ ] d'albatros et sauf
pour une véritable chaîne nous supportons les mêmes
charges aux étages supérieurs nous voulons notre
juste part du pouvoir peu nos gens
surchargent le  système qui appelez-vous les
gens, les choses seraient meilleures si nous
pouvions nous permettre de nous rencontrer pour
bien je ne ferai pas humilier mes enfants
ce qui se
passe tout le lieu de vision soit plus ferme
elle nous sommes les propriétaires
maintenant [ __ ] de temps
parler aux gens de la nourriture de vos femmes  sur les
40 autres,
tout va bien